[Music]
we have just got a total of six new
images for Godzilla xcong the new Empire
released officially through IGN and each
one of these pictures do paint a
thousand words but since we are getting
the trailer as well soon enough we shall
not speak too much on these preview
images but they do still say a lot while
at the same time bring out tons of
questions so let's dive into each one of
them in
brief the first picture Godzilla's
portrait this image shows the king of
the monsters in a new light while it is
clearly visible that this is Godzilla
here there are quite a few Visible
Changes to his face and handprint as
well to start with he has quite a few
more teeth than his previous
incarnations his eyes are red too which
points out to the fact that he may be
changed here since as usual Atomic
coloration is a bright white and blue
lastly godel's fingers seem to be longer
cementing a rumor that his
transformation here in gxk will be
really substantial and might happen
later in the movie number two Kong's
portrait then we have Kong's portrait
with his own handprint nothing much has
changed for Kong just by looking at this
picture he looks mean and with a will of
Steel but he's also gentle at heart
close to his human friends and the
closest link to the Titan world that
humans have next we see Kong with his
axe and yeah he is about to fight
something big here he seemed to have
grown his beard a bit and has a thicker
fur coat on his shoulder and back it's
cool to see him with his axe the item
that brings him at par with the
superpowered monsters of the Titan
world number three scar King's portrait
then we finally have the portrait of
Scar King the same red ape seen in the
earlier teaser promo as you can see his
nose eyes facial structure and mouth as
as well as the finger lengths bear great
differences than those of Kong while
Kong is more of a gorilla this enemy
Titan is definitely more closely related
or rather resemble the orangutangs more
closely this might mean that he is a
different species alt together it is
quite probable as we all saw him having
a lanky physique as well and longer arms
as well you know from that short clip
released this
summer number five Godzilla or shimu
this image right here is the most
interesting one so far this might either
beat Godzilla in a crysalis in the
hollow Earth evolving and morphing into
a deadly form or him trapped in eyes him
changing is actually Canon as stated by
Dr Mark Russell when they discovered him
in his underwater layer in kotm after
the oxygen Destroyer almost killed him
Russell commented that this is
incredible to see him always adapting
and evolving the reason why he has lived
for so long this is how he survive for
so long always he's adapting evolving
it's incredible anyway here he must be
doing the same thing but here in the
hollow Earth with the power SCE slowly
recharging his power and morphing into
an ultimate form beneath that cryus
Cocoon of Swords him being trapped in
ice won't really be the case since you
know those I like structures have
veins so this brings us to another
probable guess what if this is not
Godzilla at all what if this is shimu
instead and legendary has revealed the
next big threat but has tricked us into
thinking this is just the Gman so what
are the rumors circulating about this
supposed primordial Titan he has ice
powers check he's Domin and has been
hibernating for quite a while check he
has dorsal plates or spikes on his back
well well well those seem like dozle
plate Silhouettes I see another check
the veins seem to to creep up all over
the place like there are extensions of
his body like Roots transporting
nutrition into the dant hibernating
Titan and lastly the pinkish glow on the
ground as well as the ice like white
glow on top doesn't really say Godzilla
at all it says something different but
hey it could just be the Big G and we're
wrong and the last image the GVK team
Kong here in this last image we see
Alexander scarg God reprising his role
as Dr n Lynn Rebecca Hall as Dr Eileen
Andrews and Kaye huddle as Gia the E
girl seems like they are back and added
with their jumpsuits probably about to
head out in new Sci-Fi Vehicles New H
AVS to explore the hollow Earth
alongside Kong so yeah those are the new
six images that have been released I
hope you like it and do and do commment
what you think in the comments below so
like subscribe and if you're interested
in other movie monsters check out our
Channel well we'll see you in the next
one guys take care
fam